thanks to Samsung for sponsoring this
episode why did you make me do this
you're fighting so you can watch
everyone around you die think Mark
you'll live to see this world crumble to
dust and blow away what will you have
after
500 years huh it's not a bad question
sounds like an episode
of hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that asks you to think Matt Pat
think today we're diving into the
highflying Super Hero splattering World
of invincible on Prime video yeah
believe it or not there's an actual show
here it's not just a big old meme guess
what that show it is really darn good it
follows the young upand cominging
superhero Mark Grayson as he learns to
use his powers responsibly while also
living up to the high expectations set
by dear old dad Nolan sounds like your
classic superhero origin story right
wrong you see Daddy dearest has himself
a bit of a dark side even though he's
the Earth's strongest hero omn man
underneath that friendly exterior no Nan
is not the benevolent superhuman people
think he is you see Nolan is a
viltrumite a species of long-lived and
Incredibly powerful aliens that believe
in survival of the fittest they killed
off millions of their own people until
Only the strongest survived from there
they went on to form an Empire that
wants to take over the entire galaxy in
other words Nolan came to Earth not to
save Humanity but to conquer it to
subjugate it preparing it for
assimilation into his Mustachio alien
Empire he starts this process by
murdering the world's greatest heroes
the Guardians of the globe and by the
end of the first season his son Mark is
the only thing capable of stopping him
and let's just say that that family
intervention doesn't go so well and this
is where the meme we all know and love
comes in when omn man finally takes a
break from pummeling his son he tries
one last time to get Mark to understand
his position you're fighting so you can
watch everyone around you die think Mark
everyone and everything you know will be
gone what will you have after 500 years
you see Mark is half human like his mom
and half Vite like his dad he will live
longer than anyone he knows long enough
that his current relationships will feel
like an insignificant blip in time it's
an interesting perspective that our weak
short-lived human brains can't really
understand so today I want to try and
understand what exactly would living
that long do to you and more importantly
what would it do to your brain if we
fast forward a thousand years after the
life Mark currently knows has crumbled
to dust multiple times over will he
develop the same mindset as Nolan is he
faded to become a jaded empathetic
superhuman season 2 has already given us
a glimpse of countless worlds where Mark
has turned to the dark side people of
Earth the more you resist the worse this
gets so is it only a matter of time
before Marx Su comes to the very same
fate in this timeline keep your heads on
straight loyal theorists it's time to
answer this ageold old age question just
to be clear before we jump in we know
that the universe of the Invincible TV
show is separate from that of the comics
and some of the events that we referenc
from the comic Cannon might not happen
in the same way as the show if they even
happen at all will only be using comic
stuff to build off of points coming from
the show this his film Theory after all
cool cool so to kind of head this one
off at the past we should note that
omnimate so despite appearing human his
body isn't going to act the exact same
way the older we get the slower we age
you'll live for thousands of years same
thing for Mark despite being half human
Nolan says that his alien DNA is so
potent that mark is almost purely Vite
Vite DNA is so pure you're nearly
full-blooded but because we here at
theier HQ don't have ourselves access to
papers and studies related to Vite brain
chemistry we're just going to have to
move forward in this episode assuming
that they're going to act in a way
that's similar to humans let it be known
that's not me just making assumptions
for the sake of an episode clearly their
DNA is compatible enough to produce
children like Mark you see scientists
Define a species purely based on
reproductive compatibility can two
creatures mate successfully with each
other to get viable fertile offspring if
yes then hey they're the same species if
no or if The Offspring turns out to be
infertile then they're going to be
listed as different species now I'm not
going to go so far as to say that the
viltrumites are humans I'm not but the
official handbook actually will you see
the official Handbook of the Invincible
Universe expressly calls out in their
science and World building section that
viltrumites at one point had human-like
lifespans and that somewhere roughly 1
million years ago they likely shared a
common ancestor as evidenced by their
human-like biology so all of that plus
the existence of a half human like Mark
and the fact that he's shown to have
kids in the comics proves that there's
enough gen similarity between these
super aliens and US lowly earthlings to
draw at least some conclusions from
human anatomy and our own natural
development so that said then let's look
at how old age tends to affect the brain
one thing that's pretty clear Nolan you
ain't the most empathetic guy I do love
your mother but she's more like a a pet
to me don't need the Mi the aole
subreddit to answer that one friendo but
here's the thing Neuroscience tells us
that as brains grow older our capacity
to feel empathy actively declines you
see the brain is not some static
unchanging lump of gray matter it
actually evolves as we age and uh sadly
it's not evolving for the better
consider this your brain has around 100
billion neurons the way we get smarter
is for those neurons to form new
connections or synapses with the others
around it now the younger you are the
more new synapses your brain's going to
form a newborn baby brain forms synapses
at a rate of over 1 million per second
in fact a baby's brain overproduces
synapses in those early days as you get
older though your brain learns that not
all synaps are equally valuable it goes
back and it starts to focus on the ones
that really matter the most causing the
important synapses to strengthen and
just outright pruning the connections
that don't make sense to keep the whole
thing is like creating a fancy hedge
sculpture within your skull bit by bit
the wild Bush of your brain is getting
trimmed down into a beautiful Swan plant
thing don't get too excited about that
Swan sculpture though unlike the
viltrumite society killing off the
weaker synapses it ain't making your
brain stronger and stronger over time it
makes it efficient sure but it also
makes it less flexible imagine for an
instant that your brain is made out of
plastic the younger you are the hotter
that plastic is so it's easier to change
and mold this is the concept of
neuroplasticity the idea that the brain
can remain flexible and adaptive as you
age though that plastic brain starts to
cool off and get hard it becomes rigid
as a wise musician once wrote your brain
gets smart but your head gets dumb the
long and short of all of this is that
over time your brain's neuroplasticity
gets weaker and weaker and that has a
direct effect on your capability of
growing and changing that's why older
people have a hard time learning new
languages or understanding their
grandkids Tik toks or enjoying the finer
artistic merits of skibby toilet and
figuring out how a cell phone works when
an older person seems set in their ways
well that's partially because their
brains are less able to process new
information and Implement neural change
and this holds true for relationships as
well technically we get worse at making
friends as we age because our brains
aren't flexible enough to accept new
connections both neurally and personally
understanding the emotional needs of
those around you it's a lot of work for
your brain you have to have enough
neural connections to handle that sort
of mental load hence why some elderly
people tend to act less empathetic to
the needs of others and that is what I
suspect that we're seeing with omn man
here he's been caught in a Perpetual
grumpy old man phase for Millennia
there's a dragon behind you I'm on
vacation so is it that simple is Mark
faded to become just like his father
because of how old his brain's going to
become well Nolan's argument is that
you'll Outlast every fragile
insignificant being on this planet
you'll live to see this world crumble to
dust and blow away so let's take Nolan
at his word and see where that leads us
in my research I couldn't find an exact
age for omn man but we do know that he
lasts for quote thousands of years we
also know based on the official handbook
that Immortal another superhero is well
over 3,000 years old so let's just go
off of that number and estimate that
Nolan is 3,000 the average human
lifespan right now in the US is about 74
for males and 80 for females assuming
Nolan and Debbie got married when she
was 20 that would leave roughly 60 years
for them to spend together and all that
might seem like a lot from our
perspective let's look at it from omn
man's that six decade span would
literally constitute a measly 2% of his
total life but what's that really mean
well to understand that let's translate
it into equivalent terms for a human
converting that 2% to a typical human
lifespan that would be the equivalent of
spending 1.6 years of your life with
someone that is 10 times less than the
lifespan of a dog or a cats you know
goldfish that stereotypical pet that
dies and gets flushed down the toilet
even they live at least 10 years on
average even a hamster with its 2-year
average lifespan would have itself more
substantial time commitments and again
not to say that omn man has a point but
he does kind of have a point when he
says I do love your mother but she's
more like a a pet to me that's not him
being cruel that's him being generous
from his perspective and you're telling
me that in 3,000 years he's only had
himself the one kid no wonder he's
grumpy and depressed as greatest
superpower
celibacy
no no no wait never mind his greatest
superpower is that definitely that let
me tell you loyal theorists I almost
felt every single hit from omn man in
that brutal scene thanks to the sponsor
for today's video Samsung and their
brand new 98 in q8c qled 4K TV when
Samsung first approached us about doing
the sponsorship and told us about this
thing got to admit I was a bit taken
aback I mean 98 in TV that is massive
would it even be able to fit through the
front door legitimately I was concerned
that it might be a bit too big you can
have too much of a good thing after all
but I got to say after getting one for
ourselves and then having it in the
living room for the past week it's
actually a really solid fit takes up way
less space than I initially thought it's
also surprisingly thin with a super slim
design that's only like 2 in deep and
you don't actually need as much room as
you might think to get the most out of
this picture look at this thing it is a
monster it's actually got the largest
and highest quality super giant screen
on the market right now we've actually
been watching the boys recently for
research on a future Theory and the show
just looks incredible this TV makes it
feel like I am sitting in a movie
theater in my own home and this screen
isn't just big Samsung actually built in
AI upscaling technology that makes
everything look better and more crisp
and reduces noise at these large sizes
they actually call it the super siiz
picture enhancer there's also some crazy
sci-fi sounding technology mixed in
there like the neural Quantum processor
which makes everything look bright and
crisp and detailed I'm not sure how much
of it is actually coming through on the
camera cuz we're filming screens within
screens but trust me sitting here
standing here right now it is crisp and
all of this is without even mentioning
how good this thing sounds I feel like
at this point in my life I have to read
more television than I actually listen
to cuz you have to turn on close
captions for everything cuz the speakers
on so many TVs are just such low quality
but this guy right here has got Dolby
Atmos speaker technology built into it
which adds a layer of depth to the sound
that way you can hear it coming from up
down and sideways and is just so
different from anything else it also
reminds me Samsung has also built in
their new boom Smart Hub which puts
everything that you want to watch or
play right in the Forefront I don't want
to have to spend a whole lot of extra
time looking for something that I
actually want to watch when I could just
show this guy hey I've got other things
to do I want to watch my show not spend
a lot of time looking for the show that
I want to watch so having a product in
there that's like hey you're going to
watch this and you're going to enjoy it
is just a game changer all in all I got
to say I was skeptical when I first
heard about this television but now
after trying it out for the last week I
can't imagine my home without it if you
want to upgrade your TV game check out
Samsung's q8c qled 4K TV if you're Ed go
check out samsung.com not going to
regret it thanks again to Samsung for
sponsoring today's video and with that
um let me turn back into a PNG tuber and
dive back into my analysis of invincible
so just like we don't tend to mourn our
goldfish very long after it's given its
ceremonial flush omn man ain't going to
mourn his wife all that much in the
greater context of his incredibly long
life making matters worse though is
repeated grief science has shown that
the more frequently we experience
something the less sensitive we become
to it the first jump scare of a scary
game huge reaction wo oh that was the
biggest scare ever the 50th jump scare
of a game yeah not so much and honestly
it's the same thing with grief studies
show that when you're exposed to death
regularly you become desensitized to it
your brain starts to acclimate to the
flood of neurotransmitters associated
with the emotion so if omn man is truly
living life on Earth and seeing his
loved ones wiped out every 80 years or
so in 3,000 years he's going to be
seeing 40 generations of loved ones
coming and going for a human to
experience that same thing we'd have to
see the passing of a generation every 2
years imagine not being callous and Blas
about it at that rate so while Mark is
busy coming to terms with the first wave
of people who lose to his prolonged
lifespan darl dad he's been doing the
same old song and dance for Millennia
but it's not just old age and
neuroplasticity and desensitization to
grief and violence it's also an issue of
intelligence not only is omn man
outliving the people of Earth he's also
out learning the people of Earth with
centuries of extra information at his
fingertips he knows Cosmic truths that
humans would never be able to Fathom and
he's had literal thousand year stretches
to teach himself anything and everything
he could possibly want and again
research has shown that individuals with
extremely high IQ tend to have
themselves a hard time relating to the
people around them as a result so omn
man is that but times a thousand
literally as he deals with more
intelligence than any human has ever had
or ever will how can he possibly see
humans as equals if he's talking about
conquering foreign planets and we're all
busy thinking about the latest season of
selling sunset in short omn man is
literally primed to be the exact person
that we see in ible he's a hyper
intelligent Godlike being surrounded by
inferior life forms with significantly
shorter lives and smaller brains and
worst of all he's getting older and his
brain is becoming less and less flexible
ensuring he is forever stuck in his ways
which then begs the question that we
started this whole thing off with is
there any hope for Mark sure right now
he's holding his ground to protect the
human race but if we were to fast
forward 3,000 years for him would Mark
become just as cruel and heartless as
his dear old dad well believe it or not
but the answer actually comes down to
another superhero on the roster in the L
of the series vites aren't the only
long-lived characters case in point The
Immortal if you couldn't tell by the
name the immortal cannot die or at least
when he does die it tends not to stick
he always comes back the immortal can
heal from basically any wound and he
seems to never age we see that the
immortal actually predates most of human
civilization gaining his powers back
during the Bronze Age of 3300 BC before
living out lifetimes as a medieval night
in 50080 and even as President Abraham
Lincoln in the 1860s yeah that's a weird
creative choice anyway considering he's
been alive this long you would expect
him to fall into the same sorts of
issues that Nolan has except the
immortal clearly isn't cruel or
apathetic in the same way Nolan is so
what's the difference here what's the X
Factor for the immortal and how is that
going to apply to mark it actually boils
down to three things the first is the
way that the Immortals Powers seem to
work while vites like Mark and Nolan are
long-lived and can heal from pretty bad
injuries thanks to the smart atoms that
are floating around in their bodies they
can't come back from Fatal blows like
the immortal can we see tons of Ultram
mites dying both in the comics and in
the show's flashbacks but we see the
immortal come back from practically
everything in a way that's much more
akin to the classic healing factor that
you see with other comic book
superheroes that means that he's
constantly replenishing all the various
subsets of cells within his body which
would include the neurons in his brain
unlike a typical human or viltrumite
brain where neurons tend to hit a wall
before the numbers slowly decline the
immortal's brain is constantly being
replenished meaning that it's always
staying that nice hot moldable plastic
like a youngster The Immortal would be
able to quickly adapt to changing
circumstances also explaining how he's
able to master the hundreds of languages
and cultures that he's lived through
during his extended lifespan this one
sadly doesn't really apply to our Mark
example but it had to be called out
because it is a significant factor in
his success the second factor that sets
The Immortal apart from Nolan is his
relationships in the character handbook
it clearly states that the immortal's
relationships with other Heroes has
given him a renewed passion for life and
established closer connections with
friendships and teammates he's in
partnership with duplic Kate he's leader
of the Guardians of the globe The
Immortal has a sincere kinship with the
people around him despite his incredibly
Advanced age and this aderes to what we
read about in real life science studies
into the factors that give people a
greater sense of empathy deeper into
their lives show time and time again
that social interaction is key spending
time with Friends building and
maintaining social connections they are
some of the best things that you can do
for your brain's Health it exercises
that brain's empathy muscle but if those
muscles aren't worked out well they
start to at and die case in point omn
man a loner who never truly buys into
the whole team Dynamic of the Guardians
he is sent by the vites to Earth a
forgotten foreign planet and he's
stationed there alone he's a soul
soldier waiting for the right time to
strike he is isolated completely on a
planet full of aliens even his cover job
as an author emphasizes this loneliness
he's not going into the office alongside
a bunch of other co-workers he's at home
alone writing books every element of his
existence has primed him to lack empathy
so Mark spending time with William even
Amber other superheroes like the teen
team that is the sort of thing that's
going to keep him grounded those
relationships would presumably help him
stay firmly rooted on the side of good
and not join the evil space mustache
Empire years later he is starting off
with a good solid foundation of empathy
as a kid which Segways nicely into
important Point number three the most
important thing that the immortal and
Mark share being born on Earth the peak
time for children to learn empathy is
before the age of nine and they learn it
by watching others as babies we can feel
and respond to the emotions of our
caregivers as toddlers we learn more
about how others feel and we might try
to comfort them when they're upset as we
grow older especially in preschool and
early school years we get better at
understanding different emotions and
realizing that people might see things
differently than our perspective by
middle childhood we become even more
skilled at understanding others feelings
and needs it keeps developing as we grow
up but our foundational understanding of
it has to happen in these Early
Childhood years The Immortal he was born
a human he grew grew up with the social
customs and teachings of a human race
where empathy is an important part of
survival Mark same story he has a
compassionate human mother and a dad
that you know well not naturally feeling
himself at least pretended to be for the
sake of appearing normal to the outside
world as such Mark he shouldn't be
stunted in his empathetic education as
he grows older by contrast Nolan grew up
on vilum where whole swaths of the
population were wiped out for being seen
as too weak as a result he never truly
received that early childhood exposure
to the concept of compassion and empathy
ironically enough a man who has the
lifespan long enough to learn about
anything can't truly Embrace this one
essential lesson because he missed it as
a kid that said clearly Nolan's not
without hope in a flashback to Mark's
childhood Debbie explains that as people
grow older they forget to experience the
joy and excitement of the world around
them but that children can be the
vehicle for adults to remember all that
a way for them to feel empathy again and
to see that life can truly be fulfilling
and interesting and the thing that
finally breaks omn Man Marks answer to
the very question that started us down
this rabbit hole in the first place what
will you have after 500
years God I still have you it's Nolan's
love for his son Mark over his sense of
Duty to the Empire this shred of empathy
and compassion that finally breaks
through that's what's so beautiful about
this answer Mark being the thing that
grounds his father that makes him have a
change of heart it isn't just a powerful
piece of invincible thematic
storytelling this is a real
scientifically backed phenomenon one
that show us that we're never too old to
learn to feel to help others that right
there that is the true superpower an
emotional strength that can truly make
you invincible unless you know someone
actually attacks you with a weapon in
which case no you're not you're you're
just done but hey that's just a theory
oh and
[Music]
cut